[Music]
my specialty
[Music]
it's supposed to be
you
[Applause]
so check this out I am going I just was
in Austin Texas I'm now in Boston I
connected in Chicago I'm gonna speak
right now gonna go directly to the
airport fly to London hotel shower 14
hour day sleep or four hours fly to
Lisbon Portugal shower speak leave fly
to Boston Boston New York quick drinks
meeting go to sleep wake up five o'clock
in next morning go back to airport go to
the Bahamas catch some it at sea give a
keynote doc in Miami land Saturday night
even for me that is some intensive [ __ ]
simply I'm just being honest I'm just
trying to [ __ ] oh you and hit the road
simply I'm just simply I'm just simply
I'm just being honest I'm just trying to
[ __ ] with you only hit the road simply
I'm just simply I'm just simply I'm just
being honest I'm [ __ ]
can I get a handle or my emotions I want
to do this
I wasn't near his comings goings
discoveries go they wanted nicotine to
jump in this [ __ ] Maya so what should
we do Gary Vee what should people do
people should [ __ ] stop complaining
right people the [ __ ] they are good call
people should not listen to America
propaganda of fixing the [ __ ] they suck
at they should be trickling down at what
they're good at they should be confident
in certain areas but you're not gonna
become Beyonce or you know like your
bone structure is a certain way like
you're not gonna solve everything your
IQ can get a little bit better but don't
worry about the incremental figure out
what you [ __ ] put you on fire and
your halfway decent at if you're lucky
enough right now to be listening and
you're good at what you like become
tunnel [ __ ] vision because there's way
too many voices telling you what and how
and here's the other thing and this is
the big one job because you have a
humongous audience the biggest thing
that I've seen dividends from have the
conversation with the person that's
holding you back the reason most people
who are listening right now we're not
doing that thing is they're worried
about the opinion of somebody usually
their mother usually their father and
the reality is is that your spouse may
be the person holding back and you have
to have that conversation we have to get
to a place where you're doing you
because the number one thing that scares
the [ __ ] out of me is regret and you're
gonna sit there at 72 and you say I wish
I wish I wish
and whether that's money or spend more
time with your family there's a million
ways to do this not everybody wants to
buy the Jets not everybody wants a
smoked weed on the beach and Bahamas
like everybody's got a different [ __ ]
thing figure out what your [ __ ] thing
is and stop making [ __ ] [ __ ]
excuses who the president is your mom
did this like like I missed it I had
that idea for uber then why don't you
[ __ ] do it dick
how old are you
it's a it's a balance of regret and
patience look you can go hard on for
three years do nothing right wake up and
be young as [ __ ] you should really go to
a retirement home one day and volunteer
and just talk to them it won't make you
wanna do [ __ ] every minute in your life
because when you see regret in a man's
eyes it's [ __ ] painful because you
have kids of [ __ ] about it when you're
90 and you're not mobile and you're
tired and it's over you can't do it you
can't do it you can't build that company
wanted you can't spend that time with
your kid you its regret and it [ __ ]
drives the [ __ ] out of me so when I was
a young kid I made a lot of money
selling baseball cards and comic books
and toys and then I started working for
my dad's business and I was making you
know it when I was 22 to 28 I was making
thirty five to fifty five thousand
dollars a year but I had no expenses I
didn't go on vacations
I didn't buy fancy things so I saved my
money I saved my money I saved my money
and then when the till you know I had
hundreds of thousands of dollars I
didn't have millions and by the time I
was 33 34 when I had that opportunity I
still not bought a home I was still in
an apartment I was 33 years old and I
was renting and because I was saving
cash to go on the offense and so when I
had a chance to invest in those
companies I put hundreds of thousands of
dollars not millions but those hundreds
made millions made tens of millions and
so that's it nothing crazy nothing I
didn't have any crazy crazy advantage
there's a lot of people that make fifty
five thousand dollars a year when
they're 23 the problem is they go to
Coachella and they want to buy a watch
and they want to buy a BMW and I didn't
so I ate [ __ ] for thirteen years and
then I had a moment and I struck
[Music]
they're people who look up to you who
don't do what you do you mean everybody
you mean everybody they're like do you
know many people tweet hessel and work
six hours a day like I know and they ask
me well why are you up so early
yeah let's move to the next question for
I get angry by the way real quick I got
angry
if you ever say to somebody else why are
you up so early that is the quickest
tell - you are not a winning player and
that has ever crossed your mind you've
lost
[Music]
I know tens of thousands of people I
know thousands of people extremely well
I know hundreds of people deeply well
there is no correlation between how much
money someone makes and their level of
happiness I have friends who make
$47,000 a year and are the happiest
people I know their work-life balance is
on point they're part of two soccer
teams they play video games they watch
every show they want they take two
vacations that they scrap together and
they're freaking happy as hell and I
know tons of people who I grew up with
in the Silicon Valley boom who have
hundreds of millions of dollars in their
bank account and are is miserable and is
lonely and is broken as you'll ever see
so I implore all of you to please
reverse engineer and figure out who you
are and figure out what level of
monetizing and stuff you need and what
level of creativity need I promise you
one thing one thing that will catch you
very off guard
I should be way more rich I leave money
on the table every day i I've left
ungodly amounts of money on the table I
spend tons of times
spending sending DMS and engaging with
people meeting people randomly and not
cashing in I actually believe the
statement I'm about to make I think that
I love the journey and the game of
entrepreneurship so much that I have
subconsciously sabotage by financial
upside to make sure I can play this a
little longer because I fear if the
numbers keep getting too big eventually
it will take the fun out of it
when you were lucky enough like I am to
actually do something that you love so
much do something that puts pressure
against the one thing you care about
besides it which is the time I spend
with my family my family is my whole
life and being this and doing this is
the only thing that cuts into that I
could have breathed if I wasn't an
entrepreneur I didn't breathe when I
wasn't an entrepreneur that's the reason
I got these an F since school because I
just couldn't be made and I'm not
capable of that and so I think being
here excites me because I think coming
to not la San Francisco New York London
is always more fun for me it always
feels a little more practical it always
feels like there's a little bit more
chips on the shoulder which is what I
have but I want to remind everybody just
cuz he didn't grow up with a trust fund
just because you don't live in Silicon
Valley the market doesn't care if you're
good enough you will win
my cousin is at the airport could you
give me a ride yes you can come success
yeah alright what am I going
you're gonna die I did that one
that's so maybe it's patience now you're
young when you're young all of you guys
[ __ ] up because you want it so bad too
soon
I didn't even work 20 hours a day since
I was 30 and didn't talk to anybody
wait you guys wanted today yes you gotta
wait you're not coming with you I'm
double your age like you live a whole
nother [ __ ] life and you're my age
and you want a tomorrow you got kind of
real work not gonna come up with some
idea you think that will work
no but if you want to get a job yeah but
not if your own business Laurence I
forgot it
you're scared that your brother will
judge you your wife your girlfriend your
husband and most scary your mom or your
dad you need to eliminate that and/or
own that fear and put yourself in a
position to succeed because with all of
this with all of this we are now in the
greatest era for the first time ever
with no [ __ ] money with no goddamn
connections this can put you on the map
if you're good enough if you are good
enough to be up here to make bling-bling
if you are good enough nobody's stopping
you nobody if you're a [ __ ] alien the
market doesn't give a [ __ ] if you make
the best [ __ ] you will win you know suck
it was to be a nerd 20 years ago but now
the market is rewarding [ __ ] nerds
and now they're rock stars clap it up if
you're a [ __ ] nerd
[Music]
[Applause]
the best part about that was suck some
dude was clapping for him I said clap it
up and [ __ ] coming up your rising
Brian what did you feel my god me every
single day tell me what they did when
you were 15 year first 90 minutes and
you got up in your last - - what you did
today has it changed because you love it
that educated somewhere - you cared
about the one somebody was sharing that
you could ya know so the one consistent
in my life I still have nightmares it's
actually something I've never said I
just have nightmares and it was a very
reoccurring nightmare for me it was that
my family and I were going back to
Belarus on a plane and the plane would
crash and every time different people
from my family usually one or two three
people would survive it was very dark
and like probably in modern parenting
like my parents would be forced to send
me somewhere to like check out what was
wrong with me but it was consistent I
would tell you I had that dream fifty
times the reason I tell you that serene
reason you asked the question an
interesting way 15 and now the only
consistent in my life has been
perspective and gratitude it's the only
consistent in my life why I'm saying
perspective and gratitude every morning
I wake up and I make pretend that's it
that my mother or children or wife died
every day every day I did say I quickly
flash in my mind what it would feel like
because I'm very in tune with myself
if my son Xander who's four years old
got hit by a car
like crossing the street I promise you
if you're in touch with your feelings
and you can trick yourself to feel it
even right now I felt it a little bit
and really [ __ ] hurts
like nothing else matters I'm completely
driven by gratitude I keep things in
very simple perspective I went up with a
very lovely lady in the elevator she was
do you know many people who inspire
though I sure do I'm thrilled and very
in tune with my ego
I'm also very thrilled and in tune with
my humility I think I'm the best and I
think that if I disappear tomorrow
nobody
really gives a [ __ ] and so that yin and
yang is very important to me and so what
I do consistently and have for 30 years
now is I keep things in perspective this
is feel this feels real nice admiration
fam selfies but I don't know I'm just
I've got a very calc I understand what
it is
[Music]